[Music]
this beauty is the er-2 high altitude
research plane
it's NASA's science variance of the u-2
spy plane secret reconnaissance of
Russia by high-flying American new -
Jets NASA's using it to keep an eye on
the earth the oceans and the atmosphere
from as high as 70,000 feet
here's beautiful there's no weather you
see the curvature of the earth as you
scan the horizon you can see actually
see the shape of the earth Stu browse is
one of the NASA ER two pilots will join
him for a behind-the-scenes all-access
look as he prepares for a mission flying
at the edge of space that Vantage makes
the ER - the perfect tool for capturing
data with greater detail than a
satellite it's been used to study
hurricanes cosmic dust and methane leaks
but flying this thing takes some very
special gear and experience the
atmospheric pressure up there is about
1/2 of a PSI or less so human body is
not designed to function and those kind
of pressures that's what the suit is for
every time Bros flies he puts on a
custom-made quarter of a million dollar
flight suit basically you're wearing the
equivalent of a spacesuit this is the
type of thing it looks like an astronaut
would wear from what I understand it's
identical to the suits they used on the
space shuttle
to and from orbit with a couple minor
changes where the valves are placed and
of course there's our orange ours of
yellow getting into the suit is no easy
task I have to dive into the the upper
part of the suit once I get the legs on
this is the part I dread at er2
altitudes the incredibly low atmospheric
pressure would boil an unprotected
pilots blood so the suit is a must in
case I lose pressurization in the
airplane it'll capture me at a the
equivalent of 35,000 feet of altitude
and keep enough pressure on my body
where I'll stay alive
gross also has to pre-breathe pure
oxygen for a full hour before a flight
like a balloon air then a team of
support specialists drive them out to
the airfield help him into the cockpit
and ready him to fly everything about
the planes kind of a hard to do is I
call it the circus everything about the
plane is unique it's a bicycle aircraft
that has wheels that fall off from
underneath the wings on takeoff and then
we're done with them to the rest of the
flight so gross get some support from
the second pilot on the ground and
that's where this comes in this is the
ER twos chase car nice stabilizer fins
so we're about to watch you leave on a
mission we'll be chasing behind you in
the official chase car for your aircraft
watching you take off what's that
experience like
the take-off is a wonderful very
overpowered airplane long wing high
aspect ratio way the car is quickly left
behind as the er-2 s jet engine and
massive wings push it skyward every
pilots dream is to get airborne quick
and a climate about 50 degree angle of
climb initially today the er-2 is made
for long distance long duration holes
browse has flown for as long as 13 hours
while a scientific instruments installed
on the plane gather data which means he
basically has to eat and drink through a
straw it's a basically baby food and a
hub but with more flavor and of course
enjoy the views one time I actually saw
the spherical shape of the earth looking
down at night at the layout of towns in
the Sacramento Valley I actually saw a
curved surface up there gross in his
suit is about as close to being an
astronaut as anyone can come without
formally leaving the earth and heading
to the International Space Station
[Music]